os hago una pregunta cuántos de vosotros
recordáis haber visto este meme
las malas lenguas dicen que se trata de
sergei lávrov el ministro de exteriores
ruso intentando llegar a belgrado
volando por si mismo después de que los
países de la otan que rodean a serbia no
autorizarán el paso de su avión por su
espacio aéreo
estaciones otan bloqueen el avión del
enviado ruso en la visita serbia
evidentemente lávrov no pudo llegar a
belgrado pero quizás este detalle sea el
menos importante de toda esta historia
lo importante de verdad tiene que ver
con otra pregunta porque habían tres un
pais como serbia que es uno de los cinco
aspirantes oficiales a entrar en la
unión europea tenía previsto recibir con
todos los honores al ministro de
exteriores de rusia en medio de la
actual coyuntura político militar y en
plena invasión rusa de ucrania los que
hayáis visto nuestro último vídeo sobre
serbia y la historia de yugoslavia ya
sabréis por dónde van los tiros
[Música]
porque lo cierto es que en el actual
contexto no todo resulta tan sencillo
como establecer una división tajante
entre dos bloques los países por
occidente y los países pro rusia de
hecho el caso de serbia nos lanza de
bruces contra otra realidad la tercera
vía serbia está orgullosa de no formar
parte de la historia anti rusa alexander
bully ministro del interior de serbia
serbia e ignora las sanciones de la
unión europea y asegura un acuerdo de
gas computing 29 de mayo de 2022 es el
precio más favorable de europa
firmaremos un contrato de tres años y
mañana o pasado mañana discutiremos las
cantidades de gas serbia necesita
mayores cantidades del gas pero si se me
permite decirlo tendremos un invierno
seguro ya habrá más conversaciones para
determinar cuánto nos costará la
gasolina aleksandar vucic presidente de
serbia teniendo todo esto en cuenta
cualquiera podría pensar que la posición
servía está determinada única y
exclusivamente por una cuestión de
dinero es decir por ejemplo echarse en
brazos del kremlin para escapar de la
escalada de precios del gas y del
petróleo que se está experimentando a
nivel internacional sin embargo aunque
lo cierto es que el dinero siempre
influye en esta ocasión no resulta algo
tan sencillo de explicar en este vídeo
os vamos a contar por qué hoy por hoy la
república más grande de la
desintegración de la antigua yugoslavia
sigue queriendo llevarse bien con rusia
a pesar de la guerra de ucrania de
querer entrar en la unión europea pero
antes de entrar con todo este tema os
hago otra pregunta alguna vez os habéis
preguntado cómo invierten sus fortunas
los estados más ricos del mundo habéis
oído hablar de los fondos soberanos
cuáles son las mayores luchas públicas
del mundo en qué se diferencian los
fondos soberanos de norbega china y
emiratos árabes pues para responder a
todas estas preguntas no os podéis
perder el último vídeo de si lo hubiera
sabido el canal de información
financiera de activos con el que
participamos os dejamos el enlace y la
descripción y dicho esto regresemos a
serbia
[Música]
amigos amigas serbia tienen historia
bastante convulsa respecto a todo
aquello que habitualmente identificamos
con occidente o al menos con el eje
atlántico claro que sobre esta cuestión
y sobre la formación de la actual serbia
ya os contamos muchos detalles en un
reciente vídeo que también os dejo la
descripción pero para los que todavía no
lo hayáis visto aquí un breve resumen
[Música]
el punto álgido en las malas relaciones
entre serbia eeuu y el resto de aliados
atlánticos tuvo lugar en 1999 cuando
aviones de la otan bombardearon durante
casi tres meses posiciones militares y
gubernamentales a lo largo y ancho de
todo serbia incluida por supuesto su
capital belgrado la intervención de la
otan tuvo como objetivo detener los
crímenes de lesa humanidad que se
estaban cometiendo en el marco del
conflicto que mantenía la extinta
república federal de yugoslavia con los
independentistas kosovares de etnia
albanesa en concreto hablamos de un
intento de limpieza étnica contra las
minorías de origen albanés
pues bien la cuestión es que a pesar de
que la política serbia ha cambiado mucho
desde entonces este tipo de sucesos
históricos se ven siempre dejar tras de
sí una importante huella en este caso
por ejemplo explican por qué buena parte
de la sociedad serbia sigue viendo con
mucho recelo a la propia otan y en
general a todo lo que tenga que ver con
la comunidad occidental y también
explica la popularidad que sigue
teniendo rusia entre los propios serbios
al fin y al cabo o moscú se posicionó
del lado yugoslavo en las instituciones
internacionales
por ejemplo en un pasado estudio de
gallup realizado en 2016 más del 60 por
ciento de los serbios manifestaron que
seguían percibiendo a la otan como una
amenaza real ésta fue de hecho una de
las peores valoraciones que la
organización del tratado del atlántico
norte obtuvo en cualquier país del
centro y el este de europa y en esa
misma encuesta por cierto el país con
mejor opinión de la otan no fue otro que
sorpresa kosovo
pero eso no es todo
[Música]
serbia también está la cola de europa en
cuanto al apoyo popular a su adhesión a
la unión europea en 2019 por ejemplo
menos de la mitad de los serbios que
estaban a favor de pertenecer al club
comunitario y en torno al 60% el 60% de
los serbios desconfiaba de las
instituciones europeas y todo ello a
pesar de que la propia unión europea le
ha dado a serbia durante los últimos
años más de 2.800 millones de euros en
ayudas al desarrollo puede ser esto un
ejemplo de cómo las instituciones
europeas gastan dinero sin ton ni son no
sé hay lo mejor y ojo que aquí no
contamos con otras ayudas que a título
individual han entregado otros países
miembros porque en ese caso la suma
prácticamente se duplica y si por si
alguno se lo está preguntando si la
unión europea es de lejos el mayor
donante de serbia claro que si se lo
preguntáis a los propios serbios sólo
tres de cada diez tienen esa impresión y
el resto pues la mayoría dirán que rusia
porque bueno lo iré descubriendo a lo
largo de este vídeo
[Música]
el caso lo más curioso de todo este
asunto es que las leyes históricas
tampoco son ni mucho menos el motivo
principal que explica la equidistancia
de belgrado entre bruselas y moscú así
que la pregunta que podemos hacernos es
porque serbia no ha terminado de
integrarse a la unión europea ni tampoco
se está dando prisa por hacerlo pues
queridos amigos amigas la respuesta es
simple su falta de interés por acometer
las reformas que fu se la exige digamos
que belgrado apuesta por alargar todo el
tiempo que pueda su situación actual es
decir estar fuera pero en cierto modo
dentro de la unión europea ahora bien
porque éste tira y aflojas con bruselas
si la sociedad serbia desconfía tanto de
occidente porque el país mantiene su
candidatura a formar parte del club
comunitario que explica realmente los
lazos entre rusia y serbia estas son
preguntas muy importantes para uno de
los países más desconocidos de toda
europa así que descubramos lo
[Música]
jugando con los sentimientos
a ver si hay algo que los rusos han
sabido explotar desde la desintegración
de yugoslavia y la posterior formación
en 2006 de serbia como estado
independiente tal y como lo conocemos
eso ha sido la llamada hermandad eslava
una hermandad que abarca tanto la
historia como el terreno político e
incluso la identidad religiosa ahí
tenemos sin ir más lejos el caso de la
alianza religiosa entre el patriarcado
de moscú esto es la iglesia ortodoxa
rusa y la de serbia una alianza que
busca ganar influencia tanto dentro como
fuera de estos dos países por ejemplo el
patriarcado de moscú y el patriarcado de
serbia llevan años tratando de influir
juntos en la sociedad y el gobierno de
montenegro un país que se independizó de
serbia en el año 2006 fijaos
en montenegro un país que es algo más
pro occidental que serbia más del 60% de
la población se declara seguidora de la
iglesia ortodoxa serbia pues viene
montenegro la iglesia ortodoxa serbia
aprovecha su gran cantidad de seguidores
para participar activamente en la vida
política del país organizando
participando y promoviendo mítines y
protestas políticas como por ejemplo
manifestaciones contra la otan o las
instituciones y la forma de vida
occidentales
activistas anti-otan de montenegro
organizan fiesta en año nuevo la
posición pro rusa está organizando un
partido anti otan en la capital
podgorica con la bendición de la iglesia
ortodoxa serbia en montenegro pero la
religión es tan solo uno de los medios
que la rusia de putin ha encontrado para
influir en la sociedad serbia y en el
área de influencia de este país
[Música]
otro buen ejemplo lo tenemos en los
medios de comunicación en este país en
serbia rusia ha realizado importantes
inversiones en los medios de
comunicación e incluso cuenta con
publicaciones de vida gratuita hablamos
de medios que apoyan a los mandamases
locales a cambio eso sí de poder
difundir la propia agenda política de
moscú de hecho esta situación llega a
tal punto que por decirlo de alguna
forma hablar de medios de comunicación
serbios y medios rusos viene a ser como
hablar de la misma cosa belgrado
proclama oficialmente que la adhesión a
la unión europea es una prioridad pero
siempre se ha alejado de las políticas
europeas que van en contra de los
intereses rusos mientras los medios
progubernamentales se hacen eco de los
feroces mensajes que provienen del
kremlin pero por supuesto si hay un tema
que rusia sabe que aún genera escozor en
la sociedad serbia y que puede utilizar
para alejar a los serbios de la
influencia occidental ese no es otro que
kosovo kosovo es un territorio
reconocido parcialmente por la comunidad
internacional como un estado
independiente pero rusia no sólo no lo
reconoce sino que cuando se trata de
este territorio moscú siempre siempre se
pone del lado serbio y los organismos
internacionales
en cambio la posición de la unión
europea- pasa por reconocer la
independencia de kosovo ya ver ceder a
belgrado de hecho una de las condiciones
para la adhesión al club comunitario
pasa precisamente por que belgrado
abandone su beligerancia hacia kosovo y
ponga en marcha un proceso de
normalización de las relaciones
bilaterales algo que ni el gobierno ni
la propia sociedad serbia parecen
dispuestos a hacer así pues rusia se ha
convertido en el mayor valedor en las
instituciones internacionales de los
intereses serbios
[Música]
eso sí luego hay una cosa que puede
sorprender y mucho en esta especie de
ambigüedad estratégica de serbia me
estoy refiriendo al campo militar
[Música]
serbia es un país que no pertenece ni en
la otan ni a su versión rusa la
organización del tratado de seguridad
colectiva pero en cambio participa
activamente con estas dos organizaciones
al mismo tiempo serbia es estado
observador de la alianza ruso fila y a
la vez miembro del programa asociación
para la paz de la otan y de hecho
participa habitualmente en ejercicios
militares de estas dos organizaciones
digamos que la neutralidad o más bien la
ambigüedad en el campo militar es algo
particularmente importante para belgrado
no vamos a cambiar nuestra política
hacia rusia continuaremos con nuestras
relaciones de hermandad no cambiaremos
de política no nos uniremos a la otan ni
a la csc serbia tiene su propio ejército
para proteger sus tierras y sus cielos
aleksandar vucic presidente de serbia
los que hayáis visto lo anterior vídeo
ya sabéis que entre el 2015 y el 2021 el
gobierno serbio disparó su presupuesto
militar más de un 70 por ciento así que
digamos que las palabras del presidente
no parecen precisamente un farol serbia
tiene entre ceja y ceja a ser capaces
por sí mismos de garantizar su soberanía
al fin y al cabo hablamos de un estatus
de una apuesta por la amigo edad que no
les ha ido precisamente mal atentos
el puente serbio
amigos amigas la aceptación oficial de
la candidatura de un país para entrar en
la unión europea conlleva por sí mismo
importantes ventajas tanto en el plano
económico como en la libre circulación
de personas y el caso de serbia
obviamente no es una excepción hablamos
de ventajas como la exención de visados
para poder viajar los paquetes de ayudas
directas o el acceso preferente al
mercado comunitario sin aranceles ni
sobre regulaciones y barreras para un
montón de productos
desde el 2013 gracias al acuerdo de
estabilización y asociación con la unión
europea un estatus previo a la adhesión
serbia tiene un acceso prácticamente
libre al mercado comunitario este
acuerdo ha hecho que las exportaciones
de serbia a la unión europea se disparen
que actualmente supongan según el año
entre el 58 y el 68 por ciento de todas
las ventas al exterior del país además
los países del bloque comunitario son
también los mayores inversores en la
economía serbia desde el año 2010
suponen entre el 60 y el 80 por ciento
de toda la inversión directa extranjera
que entra cada año en el país
[Música]
en definitiva una creciente
interconexión que le ha sentado muy bien
a la economía serbia claro que con todos
estos datos en la mano bien podríamos
pensar no sé que en belgrado estarán
como locos por terminar de integrarse la
unión europea lo antes posible verdad
pues no lo cierto es que no de hecho los
informes anuales que bruselas realizan
para informar de los avances en las
reformas económicas políticas y
legislativas que serbia tiene que llevar
a cabo de cara a su membresía en europea
lo que más se repite es la expresión
escasos avances y es que justo aquí
aparece el punto que diferencia a serbia
de los otros países balcánicos que ya
han entrado en el club comunitario o
están en camino de hacerlo próximamente
hablamos de la asociación económica con
rusia y con los aliados de rusia
[Música]
además de mantener un acuerdo de
estabilización y asociación con la unión
europea serbia también tiene un estatus
de acceso preferente al mercado de la
unión económica euroasiática el bloque
económico liderado por moscú que incluye
a rusia bielorrusia armenia kazajistán y
kirguizistán
evidentemente este mercado es mucho
muchísimo más pequeño que el mercado
comunitario pero también conlleva una
ventaja el acceso en condiciones
preferentes al sector energético y a las
materias primas y no sólo eso otro
importante beneficio para belgrado es
que muchas empresas e inversores
occidentales han apostado precisamente
por serbia para aprovechar su libre
acceso tanto al mercado europeo como al
mercado de la unión eurasiática de esta
forma el país funciona como una especie
de puente entre ambos bloques lo que ha
favorecido a la por otra parte rne que
ante economía nacional
[Música]
de esta forma empresas occidentales y
rusas como por ejemplo microsoft lukoil
cocacola siemens o fia tienen
importantes inversiones para aprovechar
precisamente el puente económico serbio
entre la unión europea rusia y la órbita
de moscú y luego por supuesto otro de
los motivos por los que a serbia le ha
convenido y mucho llevarse muy bien con
moscú y no entrar en líos con el kremlin
ha sido su altísima dependencia de rusia
materia energética porque amigos amigas
y lo de alemania ya nos puede parecer
escandaloso las cifras de serbia van
todavía más allá
para que os hagáis una idea en 2020 de
las importaciones serbias de gas desde
rusia supusieron el 64 por ciento del
total y en el caso del petróleo crudo y
del glp es aún más podemos hablar de más
del 75 por ciento de las importaciones
energéticas de serbia o una situación de
la que por cierto viene alertando eeuu
en reiteradas ocasiones el 9 de
septiembre de 2016 eeuu urge a serbia y
eslovenia a que diversifiquen sus
fuentes de energía para más inri la
principal petrolera serbia nis está
controlada por la rusia gazprom que
posee el 56 15 por ciento de las
acciones porque amigos amigas si en algo
se han esforzado los rusos ha sido
precisamente entender bien pero que muy
bien atado al sector energético de
serbia y seguro seguro que esto nos
sorprende y luego en total aunque muy
lejos de la unión europea-rusia es el
segundo inversor en el país en
definitiva que el grado no tiene la
menor prisa por llevar a cabo todas las
reformas que pide bruselas para
convertirse en miembro pleno de la unión
[Música]
al fin y al cabo ya disfrutar de muchas
de las ventajas del mercado único y
desde luego la entrada definitiva en la
web se podría poner punto y final a esa
posición de puente que geopolíticamente
hablando tanto parece interesarle a ver
nada claro que un aumento porque ahora
todo esto podría haber cambiado ahora
las acciones internacionales y el
impacto que éstas seguramente tengan
sobre la economía rusa podría cambiar
por completo estos planes y hacer que
serbia se ponga las pilas para sumarse
de una vez por todas a la unión europea
pero tener una cosa presente sea como
sea los profundos lazos culturales
históricos políticos y económicos que
unen la serbia con rusia siembran la
duda de si servía no terminaría
convirtiéndose en algo así como una
especie de caballo de troya y ojo porque
este es un miedo que también parece
estar creciendo en bruselas pero
llegados hasta aquí turno para ti crees
que serbia terminará formando parte de
la unión europea qué opinas de que
belgrado haya optado por mantener su
posición amistosa con el kremlin a pesar
de la invasión rusa de ucrania como
siempre podéis dejarnos vuestras
opiniones por aquí abajo en los
comentarios y ya sabéis si este vídeo se
resultó interesante no olvidéis darle a
like suscribiros a visual político una
vez más muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]